alors que la finale de the re all star
s'est déroulée samedi dernier sur tf1
les téléspectateurs ont pu assister au
sacre dalle sylla en gagnant de cette
édition spéciale
mais durant la soirée ce n'est pas la
seule surprise qui a eu lieu en pleine
émission l'un des coaches a pris la
parole pour faire une grande annonce
c'est jennifer présente dès la première
année de l'émission qui a annoncé
qu'elle quittait définitivement le jury
du programme c'est probablement la
dernière fois que je suis dans ce
fauteuil rouge un petit coup de tonnerre
pour les fans de l'émission même si elle
n'a participé qu'à six saisons sur les
neuf elle s'est imposée comme un visage
fort de the voice est vous étiez mal
d'artisans c'est toujours le même
frisson cette émission oui avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour tous les autres
coaches je le vois clair on va pas se
quitter comme ça ce sera ailleurs de son
côté nico ce qui a débuté à ses côtés
dans star academy sur tf1 en 2001
aimerait voir perdurer cette relation
particulière entre une petite décennie
ensemble dans les vols c'est vous qu'on
sait que la prochaine vous serez pas
avec moi sur un plateau de télé ou
ailleurs un poste qui était comme ça un
départ qu'elle annonce comme définitif
mais qui n'est pourtant pas le premier
alors the voice all-stars jennifer
annonce son départ j'y crois
triste nouvelle non mais alors ces mecs
ce qu'ils en pensent
bah oui
quoi dans ses émissions sur mes ex l'oci
l'annexé les bains jean passé voilà à la
jennifer alors j'ai essayé nous
renseigner un petit peu auprès de tf1
alors en fait je nie fermement avec
quitterais the voice of stars parce
qu'elle va se concentrer sur son album
et sa tournée et rien n'empêche qu'elle
revienne en 2023 enfin les portes ne
sont pas fermées des missions donc donc
c'est une
vision autre chose de prendre surtout
elle qui donne moi c'est une réponse de
preuve qu'il a eu énormément parler de
production donnant sur une chose est ce
la porte ouverte mais on en a parlé il
ya deux semaines on a parlé du fait
qu'elle avait envie de de quitter le
plateau mais c'est simplement ce que les
nouvelles règles de the voice ne lui
conviennent pas on le sent bien on sent
que les crocs ce battle le fameux truc
des pokémon avec joe cole et sa monnaie
qui tu envoies ton talent une faute
stratégique et tout ça c'est quelque
chose qui qui qui lui convient pas et
qui n'est pas dans l'adn du sauvage pour
lequel elle a signé donc moi son départ
j'y crois totalement je pense vraiment
et une brève dans public apparemment les
tv n'a contre la production non mais
c'est juste cette nouvelle règle donc
qu'elle ne connaissait pas et qui lui a
pas plu et on l'a toujours très rouge
sera jaune magali pourquoi il sera jaune
gilles vannelet de changer ça perturbe
peut-être les couleurs pas terrible yens
oui le magal moi je trouve qu'elle a été
extrêmement touchante oui franchement ça
ne donne pas vraiment envie de rire là
tu fais tes blagues elles sont nulles
mais non je rigole non mais je la trouve
touchant je trouve que là vraiment elle
a fait un vrai moment de télé et je
trouve ça très classe de sa part
d'annoncer son départ bah comme ça et
que se soit montré et qu'elles
ressentent c'est qu'elle fasse ressortir
ses émotions plutôt que comme souvent
beaucoup d'animateurs quitte l'émission
mais après on sait pas ce qui s'est
passé et là on a vu cette sensibilité
qu'elle avait et mais c'est pour ça
qu'elle venait de se faire sur moi je
trouverais truc même question oui vous
avez peur de vous perdre pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez un colis avec votre monde
ça c'est pourquoi pensez-vous
on menait alors scellé même veine que je
[Rires]
m'égare est très bon c'est très joli
récit des violets le colis parce que
c'est lui
qui me l'a offert un bijou tina perché
passé doit dire son nom ne
connaît jilal même nom il a le même nom
que la l'escalope l'escalope qu'on
commence c'est pascal paillard
demandé quelqu'un qui a fait la star
academy bosse
jusqu'à quoi vous en souvenez pas
pourquoi je voudrais oublier moi
et me dans la
fun mais performance extraordinaire ça
c'est sûr parce qu'ils étaient pas de
choix du meilleur et eu cette chance à
vous en rappeler ça s'appelle de la
saignée de l'oreille
attendez attendez globalement le
vendredi un super beau coup de colère
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu la spc ici je n'ai pas peur
des chroniqueurs
dont elle a la chance de pouvoir faire
ce dont tu as l'air enjoué elle est
connue elle est attendue dans le
programme de vol si elle revient en lui
ouvrira grand les bras là la chance de
pouvoir faire son album elle a aussi
envie de s'occuper un peu de ses enfants
après ajaccio où elle habite il ya plein
de choses alors alors donc pas
maintenant mais je vois pas pourquoi
elle resterait de voice est de ce fait
un petit un petit rtt elle fait une
petite année sympathique qu'elle
reviendra
alors qu'un pas caisse ou plaint pas de
mon demande témoin un nom mais elle se
plaint pas du tout le monde en connaît
[Musique]
beaucoup là bas en afrique avec moi elle
m'a fait chier quoi c'est sa faute il y
fait bon oui twitter revenus autonomes
ouais une photo wendy ne lâche avec mon
coeur que ce soit
pendant la messe numérique
wi2wi cabinda contrairement à ma gagner
chez eux les jeux les patrons et
bouleversante moi je me suis demandé est
allé pleure parce qu'elle part ou quoi
ou alors elle aura pu son chèque
deux roues amel bent qui était hyper
stress d'un programme taille limite tu
regardes
d'argent
elle était enceinte aussi au début de
the voice ont comme au niveau des
hormones elle était ultra sensibles ces
bouffées dans les manières financer les
grossesses
et je suis fou qu'il
avait à mon avis à mon avis elle va
revenir